Tucked away in a cupboard somewhere in the medical
department of the University of Sao
Paulo is a 40-year-old human skeleton.
To the trained eye, the bones offer a window into
their former owner’s life - a hip fracture points
to an old motorbike accident and a tiny hole in
the left cheekbone hints at severe sinusitis.
That aside, it's pretty much a standard issue
human skeleton, one that's helped hundreds of
Brazilian forensic science students to better
understand how to identify human remains.
But this apparently unassuming human skeleton
hides one hell of a secret. Because in life,
it belonged to one of the most evil
human beings ever to walk the earth.
Now I admit there's a fair amount of hyperbole
going around on YouTube these days, so I'd
forgive you for thinking I'm exaggerating here
for effect. But trust me, this is not clickbait.
You see, the classroom skeleton at Sao
Paolo University once belonged to a nazi
war criminal who was personally responsible
for the deaths of an estimated 400,000
people. That on its own is mind bogglingly
evil, but it gets even worse. Because this
man *also* used his position as a doctor working
at the notorious Auschwitz concentration camp to
undertake some of the most brutal,
depraved experiments ever carried
out in the name of science - experiments
that used live humans as their subjects.
This nazi mass murderer was called Josef
Mengele, but the inmates at Auschwitz had
another, more fitting name for him -
the Angel of Death. This is his story.
Delving into the early years of history's
most twisted individuals often turns up
tales of hardship and abuse, but that
wasn't the case for young Josef Mengele.
He was born in the picturesque Bavarian
town of Günzberg on the 16th March 1911,
and his father was the founder and owner of
a successful farming equipment manufacturer.
As a lad, Josef was one of those absolute
bastard's who seem to be good at everything - he
was a strong student and capable sportsman with
an interest in the arts, and combined with his
good looks and natural charm, he enjoyed no
shortage of interest from the opposite sex.
He excelled in further education, too, studying
philosophy in Munich, Medicine in Frankfurt,
and eventually earning himself a PhD in
Anthropology. In 1937 he got a job at the
Institute for Hereditary Biology and Racial
Hygiene in Frankfurt. There, he worked under
Otmar Freiherr von Verschuer, a Dutch nobleman
and scientist with an interest in eugenics and
a belief in forcibly sterilising people with
‘undesirable’ genetic traits. In other words,
he was an arsehole, and Mengele quickly bought
into his arseholy ideas, particularly the ones
about a racial hierarchy that put people like
him on top, and everyone else on the bottom.
A man with Mengele's scientific interests
was a natural fit for the racist ideology
of the Nazi Party, and he became
a member in 1937, signing up to
Hitler's personal paramilitary
- the SS - the following year.
Those were happy times for Mengele, and he
married his first wife - Irene - in July
1939. When the Second World War kicked off
two months later, Mengele volunteered for
medical service with the Waffen-SS, and by
all accounts he was an excellent soldier,
serving primarily in France and Russia
and winning several medals in the process,
including an Iron Cross First Class for
rescuing two men from a burning tank.
His time on the front lines came to an end in
1942 when he was wounded in battle, but a man
with a mind like Mengele’s still had his uses,
and in early 1943 he was transferred to Auschwitz.
He was given the role of camp physician,
though that title was so inappropriate it's
almost laughable. Nazi doctors like Mengele never
treated the inmates, who were simply dispatched to
the gas chambers when they fell seriously ill.
No, Mengele's duties at Auschwitz had nothing
to do with patient care - in fact, they'd
have given Hippocrates of Kos an aneurysm.
As well as being a place to commit mass murder
on a scale never before seen in history,
concentration camps like Auschwitz were also
used for forced labour. And so the first thing
to do when a new trainload of inmates arrived
was determine who among them was fit enough to
work. This process was known as 'Selection,' and
it was the job of Nazi doctors to make the call.
It's estimated that at least 75% of all the
people who arrived at Auschwitz - including
almost all children, pregnant women, and the
elderly - were immediately deemed unfit for work
and sent straight to the gas chambers. To put that
into context, it’s thought that close to a million
people were murdered as soon as they arrived
at the camp. Under Mengele’s direct orders,
400,000 souls - including tens of thousands
of children - were sent to the gas chambers.
There are reports that some SS doctors found
this task somewhat unpleasant - I mean,
you'd bloody hope so - but not
Mengele: he relished it. In fact,
he enjoyed his work so much he was regularly
seen smiling and whistling on the job,
and he'd even turn up to help out
when he wasn't officially on shift.
But it turned out there was an ulterior motive for
all that overtime. You see, Mengele had realised
Auschwitz was the perfect place to continue his
research into the empirical superiority of the
Aryan race. In the eyes of the Nazis, inmates at
the camp weren't truly human. And that opened up
certain... opportunities: using a grant secured
by his old mentor Arsehole Freiherr von Verschuer,
Mengele built a lab at Auschwitz that would
use the camp's inmates as its test subjects.
That's why he was so keen to take part
in Selections - they gave him an excuse
to scan the crowds for anyone with an obvious
genetic abnormality he could study - club feet,
cleft palettes, people with dwarfism or
hunchbacks - Mengele collected them all
for his own private menagerie of genetic oddities.
But there was something he prized even more
highly than quirky genes: identical twins.
So-called 'twin studies' remain an
important tool in science even today,
because identical twins have identical
DNA (well almost identical, but that’s
a topic for another video). Some scientists
believe this clone-like property makes twins
invaluable for studying the age old
question of 'nature versus nurture.'
Mengele felt the same way, and he planned
to use his lab to prove that genes - namely
Aryan ones - were the deciding factor in
the development of desirable traits or
‘phenotypes.’ He also hoped to find a way to
help German mothers give birth to strong Aryan
twins of their own to more quickly repopulate
the world according to Hitler’s mad ideal.
Think of the scariest, most disturbing
scenes from the most extreme horror films
you've seen and they won't even come close to
the living nightmare that was Mengele's lab.
We'll likely never know the full extent of
what went on in those blood-soaked corridors
because the mad doctor himself destroyed
most of his records when it became clear
Germany would lose the war, but what
we do know is almost beyond belief.
Some of Mengele’s twins had their eyes
injected with chemicals in an attempt
to turn them Aryan blue, while others were
made to endure extensive surgeries without
anaesthesia, including amputations, organ
removal, and castration. In some cases,
one twin was deliberately infected with
a disease like typhus or tuberculosis.
When it killed them, the surviving
twin would be murdered too so that
a comparative autopsy could be carried
out to study the effects of the disease.
Mengele claimed to be a man of science
looking for answers to important questions,
but that was just a mask. Sometimes that facade
slipped entirely, revealing the monster beneath.
One Auschwitz inmate saw Mengele throw a
newborn baby off a camp roof, and another
saw him kill 14 children in a single night by
injecting chloroform directly into their hearts,
one after the other. Another survivor described
how Mengele once sewed two children together in
an attempt to create artificially conjoined
twins. They died of gangrene two days later.
This wasn’t science, it was murder of
the most sadistic variety imaginable.
Of the 1500 sets of twins taken into Mengele's
lab, just 200 individuals are thought to have
come out alive. Those that died were dissected,
with various parts of their anatomy removed for
further study. Of particular interest
were the eyes, and one entire wall of
the lab was full of them, each pinned in
place like a butterfly in a display case.
Several survivors report that, outside of his lab,
Mengele often showed kindness to his subjects,
insisting that they call him Uncle and handing out
candy and milk to the younger children. Sweets in
the morning, scalpels in the evening - what kind
of person is capable of something like that?
This utter depravity continued unchecked
for 2 years until the Angel of Death was
forced to leave Auschwitz just before its
liberation by the Soviets in January 1945.
He fled to Czechoslovakia, where he was
eventually captured by the Americans.
I wish I could tell you that at this point
in the story, Josef Mengele finally got what
he deserved. That he was put on trial in
Nuremberg and left to rot in the deepest,
darkest dungeon for the rest of his days. Sadly,
that isn't quite how this story goes. In fact,
that is the exact *opposite,* of how this
story goes. But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Just one month after he was taken into custody,
Mengele, one of the most wanted individuals
on planet earth, was released as a free man.
As for why - he simply hadn't been correctly
identified. There were so many nazi war criminals
knocking around at the time that the Allies
were having trouble keeping up, and despite
initially being registered under his real name,
somehow Mengele slipped through the cracks.
He wasted no time going to ground, working as a
farmhand in deepest Bavaria for 4 years before
eventually escaping Germany altogether
along one of the so-called ratlines that
provided escape routes for Nazi war
criminals, mostly to South America.
Mengele was able to convince the Red Cross to
issue him a passport under the name Helmut Gregor,
and he used it to make his way to
the Argentine capital Buenos Aires.
To begin with he was sheltered by nazi
sympathisers, but eventually he bought
himself a swanky apartment in the city
centre. To give you an idea of just how
unconcerned he was about the possibility of his
past catching up with him, Mengele applied for
Argentine citizenship under his real name, and
he soon got a job working as a regional sales
representative for - and I'm not making this up
- Karl Mengele & Sons, his father's own company.
By the late 50s, he'd apparently decided
the folks back in Europe must have put
that whole Holocaust business behind
them, because he flew back to Germany
to visit family and catch up with some old
buddies on a skiing holiday in Switzerland.
Quick reminder here that we're talking about a
man who was personally responsible for *400,000*
murders. And he was just...
going about his business as
though the Second World War had never happened.
If you're wondering how the hell that
was possible - how this despicable
human being somehow got away Scott free
- the answer is actually quite simple:
the rest of the world thought he was dead. Mengele
hadn't been seen since he slipped through the
American's fingers in 1945, and his own family
had gone on record to confirm he'd been killed.
If he hadn't been so monumentally
stupid as to use his real name in
his new life in South America, there's a
good chance the wider world would never
have realised he survived the war.
Thankfully he *was* that stupid,
and that was all it took for famous nazi
hunter Simon Wiesenthal to get on his trail.
In the aftermath of the war, Mengele's
wife Irene hadn't fancied relocating
to South America with her mass-murdering husband,
and in 1954 the two were officially divorced. Not
that Mengele minded - he took the opportunity to
marry his dead brother's widow. He really
was a classy guy wasn't he. But of course,
marriages and divorces leave a pretty bloody
obvious paper trail. And not only did those
documents confirm Mengele was still alive, they
also listed his home address in Buenos Aires.
Having realised Mengele was still
at large, Simon Wiesenthal convinced
the West German government to issue a
warrant for his arrest. Unfortunately,
when police arrived at Mengele's apartment in June
1959, the Angel of Death had already taken flight.
As it happens, Mengele had no idea the
authorities were onto him - he'd gone
to ground for entirely different reasons.
Along with working for the family firm,
Mengele had been doing a bit of illegal doctoring
on the side, including performing backstreet
abortions. When one of those procedures
went wrong and a young girl died,
the local press started sniffing around.
They say no publicity is bad publicity,
but I'm pretty sure that doesn't apply
when you're a mass-murdering shit face..
Worried that the attention might lead
to some very uncomfortable questions,
Mengele swapped Buenos Aires for a
remote farm in Southern Paraguay,
where he gained citizenship in 1959 under
the incredibly clever alias 'José Mengele.'
Despite this frankly embarrassing attempt at
covering his tracks, Mengele proved surprisingly
hard to pin down in Paraguay, and neither Simon
Wiesenthal nor Mossad - the Israeli Secret
Service - were able to bring him to justice.
Thankfully, their combined efforts hadn't gone
unnoticed by Mengele himself - he now knew he was
a wanted man, and that knowledge changed his life.
He was forced to relocate once again, this time
to Brazil, and the spectre of capture hung over
him constantly, an incessant worry that frayed his
nerves and eventually began to impact his health.
By the early 1970s he'd developed a nervous
habit of chewing the tips of the moustache
he'd grown to alter his appearance, a
compulsion that got so bad a giant ball
of beard-hair formed in his intestines, almost
killing him. Almost murdering himself with his
own moustache seems to have shaken Mengele up
a bit, because he briefly considered heading
back to Germany to seek medical help.
The trouble was, he couldn't afford it.
By this time there now multiple bounties
on Mengele's head, which made getting
work risky, and his support network of nazi
sympathisers had begun to dwindle. In fact,
several of those who still knew his real
identity had started to blackmail him,
threatening to reveal his
secret if he didn’t pay up.
Mengele kept a diary in the
later years of his life,
and the entries within reveal a man
who was depressed, poor, paranoid,
pessimistic and constantly poorly. It's far from
the justice he deserved, but it's something.
Sadly, the diary also revealed that Mengele
never felt remotely remorseful for the
unspeakable things he did, nor did his belief in
the Nazi ideology ever waver, even until the end.
Speaking of ends, Mengele's came in 1979 when
he suffered a stroke while swimming in the sea
not far from Sao Paulo. He survived the
stroke, but not the subsequent influx
of several litres of seawater into his
lungs. He drowned on the 7th February,
almost 35 years after leaving Auschwitz,
and was buried under a false name.
It wasn't until 1985 that the rest of the
world learned of his fate. West Germany,
Israel, and the U.S.A. had finally begun
to make a combined effort to find him,
and the operation eventually led them
to a cemetery on the outskirts of Sao
Paulo and a simple grave marked
with the name Wolfgang Gerhard.
The bones within were exhumed and a forensic
analysis concluded that they likely belong
to Josef Mengele, but doubts remained. At the
time the bounty on Mengele's head stood at 3.4
million US dollars, and some people believed
the body in the grave was a red herring,
planted there by his family to
throw investigators off the scent.
That theory was put to bed in 1992 when
DNA testing confirmed the bones belonged
to Mengele. For obvious reasons,
his family weren't keen to have the
remains returned to Germany, which is how
they ended up locked away in a box in Sao
Paolo's Institute for Forensic Medicine.
They remained there for some 25 years,
before a faculty member realised he
could put them to use as a teaching aid.
We're used to the idea that true, unfiltered
evil is something that can't be concealed.
Whether it's the terrifying clown makeup of John
Wayne Gacy or the cold, dead eyes of Ed Gein,
we assume that a rotten inside will eventually be
visible on the outside, too. But that wasn't the
case with Josef Mengele. This could be a picture
of your mate's favourite grandfather (well,
minus the SS insignia). He was handsome, he
was charming, he smiled openly and often.
And yet, this man wasn't merely a wolf in sheep's
clothing - he was a monster draped in the skin of
a man. During the Second World War he committed
some of the most unfathomably evil acts of any
human being that's ever lived, and he did it all
with a smile and a sweetie. For my money, the fact
that he was never made to pay for those crimes
remains one of the biggest travesties of our time.
Thanks for watching.